President Trump says he supports
background checks on gun purchases in
the wake of last week's mass shootings
and El Paso and Dayton Ohio the
president made the remarks Friday before
attending two fundraisers in the
Hamptons rich Enclave on New York's Long
Island today he begins his ten-day
vacation at his New Jersey Golf Club Ben
Tracy is traveling with the president
Ben good morning good morning so the
president is not pushing for any sort of
ban on assault weapons but he says the
time has come for what he is calling
meaningful background checks but it's
still not clear if he can get
Republicans and the NRA on board I think
we could have some really meaningful
background checks as he left the White
House Friday President Trump had one
word on his mind we have to have
meaningful background checks
I took it about meaningful had that word
meaningful background check
he never defined what meaningful means
the President did have several calls
this week with Wayne LaPierre the head
of the National Rifle Association it has
opposed any expansion of background
checks I think Wayne and the NRA will
either be there or baby will be a little
bit more neutral and that would be okay
too mr. president but if the NRA does
not support that effort will you fight
them on it well we'll see where the NRA
will be but we have to have meaningful
background checks the president also has
to have Republicans he said this about
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
he's totally on board but a McConnell
spokesperson said he didn't endorse
anything specific
meanwhile the president continues to
give North Korea a pass on its recent
string of missile tests Kim jong-un
launched two more missiles on Friday the
president seems more focused on his
correspondence with the North Korean
dictator he really wrote a beautiful
repay from top to bottom a really
beautiful letter president Trump says
that Kim jong-un is upset about the
joint South korea-us military exercises
that are currently taking place and
that's why he's launching these missiles
the president called them wargames which
is what North Korea calls them and the
president says he doesn't like them
either because they cost too much Dana
and Tracey thank you